All [clears throat] right, so we're
going to start today with another MobLab
game. Hopefully everyone can get logged
in.
Uh this is going to be the game we're
going to play is called the ultimatum
game.
And this is probably the most famous
game that's used in laboratory
experiments about economics.
So the way it's going to work is that
you're going to be randomly assigned to
two roles. One of you is going to be the
proposer and one of you is going to be
the responder.
And there's some pot of money and the
proposer just proposes how that money is
split between them and the other person.
And then the other person can choose to
accept that in which case you split the
money in that way
or reject that in which case no one gets
any money.
So player one makes an ultimatum. This
is how much money you get. This is how
much money I get. Take it or leave it.
Player two says, I'll take it or I'll
leave it and then we both get nothing.
So that's the game. I think in this
version you have $100 maybe to split.
So let's play and see what happens.
So here we have a table of the results.
What we can see is the blue circle,
these are offers that were accepted. So
this is the amount that the proposer
offered the responder could receive out
of 100.
And then the orange circles are offers
that were rejected.
And then we see the averages here.
So we definitely see that on average
uh at least especially in these early
rounds, the higher offers were more
likely to be accepted and the lower
offers were more likely to be rejected.
It looks like a lot of the offers were
above zero except maybe one down here.
Someone offered zero. Um anyone who
played want to share their thoughts
about how they approached this and how
they thought about this game?
So what about when you were the Yeah, go
ahead. I was the one who was receiving
the offer. Okay. So as long as the
amount was positive, I would just
receive it because otherwise I don't
want to get zero.
Okay. So that's sort of the
ultra-rational way to play uh and that's
sort of the
what game theory would propose. Often in
practice we don't see that happening, uh
but that's a great way to play. So other
people who who rejected positive offers,
what was your thinking about that? Yeah.
All right, so I was less rational. If no
one offered me 50, then I was like
well, I I don't like you, so I'm not
going to accept that. Okay, great. Fair
give me fair 50. Right. Uh so a lot of
people have this reaction about
fairness, right? So this sort of
captures people's idea of fairness. Some
people are willing to to sacrifice
financial gains in order to punish
people who you might feel have morally
wronged you, right? Or done something
that's fundamentally unfair. Again, it's
a pretty cheap way to punish someone
when there's no money on the line. If it
was $50,000 and they gave you 49,000
you probably still accept it, right? Uh
but yeah, that's that's useful. And then
what about people who were proposing?
What was your
uh
reasoning?
Did you propose an even split? Did you
propose more for yourself? What did you
do?
It's very quiet.
Someone proposed
Some people proposed It looks like I
guess if we look at the game, it looks
like no one gave more than 50 to the
other person. So it looks like some
people felt let's be generous and give
50 and then other people wanted to keep
a little more for themselves. Usually
what happens in this game is people
their reasoning is well, I anticipate
the responder might be a bit like you
suggested and might not be happy with me
if I give them nothing.
But I don't have to give them all the
full half. Maybe I'll give them 30 or
40. That's a pretty common response and
then the hope is that the person will
accept this. Um here you actually played
it in multiple rounds. Did anyone think
about the dynamics of this game?
Um
So I think that's an important
consideration in this game. Today we're
going to think about a static version of
this game.
Uh but if you're playing this
repeatedly, you might think well,
depending on what I do in this round,
that might affect the way the person
will play in future rounds. If they know
that I'm someone who rejects really low
offers, maybe they'll be forced or
motivated to offer more to me in the
future and that's something we'll think
about when we get into repeated games.
So let's uh
close this
and move into more of a formal analysis
of this game.
So the topic for today is going to be
what's called backward induction, but I
think the best way to go about it is
just to think through this example and
then later in the class I'll give a more
formal definition. So let's look at an
easier version of the ultimatum game. I
think in the game you played, you could
choose any number between maybe zero and
100. Let's make it a bit simpler, so
let's see the ultimatum game with maybe
$3 at stake.
And let's
think about how this game works. So we
have player one
who's what we would call the proposer
and player two who's the responder.
And the proposer is proposing how to
split the $3 between themselves and the
other person.
But we're going to keep track of it as
thinking about the proposer P1
makes an offer.
So we'll think of the offer as what they
offer to the other person.
And that means that they will keep the
remaining amount. So there's two numbers
going on, but because the numbers always
sum to $3, we only have to keep track of
one of those numbers and we'll keep
track of the number which is the amount
the responder would get.
And then
the responder player two can either
accept
or reject this offer.
And as usual, we're going to assume that
people are risk-neutral so that monetary
payoffs coincide with utilities.
So let's try to represent this game in
the extensive form.
So first we have player one.
And how much can they offer to player
two? Well, we'll assume that they can
only make offers that are in even dollar
amounts just to make it a bit simpler.
So they can either offer zero, one, two,
or three.
And each of these offers, it's then
player two's turn to move.
Of course, these are all in separate
information sets, right? We have to
remember that player two observes the
offer that is made by player one. The
responder observes the offer made by the
proposer so they can distinguish these
offers and then they choose accept or
reject which I'll call AR.
And now let's make sure we get the
payoffs right. So whenever the second
player rejects the offer, no matter what
the offer was, both players get zero,
right? That's the rule of the game. If
the offer is rejected, you both get
zero. So we're going to have zero zero
zero zero
zero zero and zero zero.
Now if the offer is accepted, then the
number here is the offer that goes to
player two which means player one gets
the remainder of the $3. So up here it's
going to be three zero, right? The
accepted offer is an offer of zero to
player two and that means player one
keeps three.
Here it's going to be
two one. The offer is one to player two.
It's accepted and that means the first
player, the proposer, keeps two. Then we
have one two
and zero three.
So here's the game.
And
the first way the first approach to
analyzing this game is let's think about
how we can represent this game in
strategic form.
Okay? So what is a strategy? Let's write
down what the strategies are for the
players.
What about for
player one and for player two? So for
player one, what is a strategy in this
game?
Well, it's just an offer.
Right? So for player one, a strategy is
an element of the set zero, one, two,
three.
They just choose how much do they offer
to player two, to the responder.
What about a strategy for player two?
This is a little trickier, right?
How do we represent a strategy for
player two or what what kind of
mathematical [snorts] object is it?
Yeah?
Right. So it's a function with a four
things which we can represent as a
four-tuple. Let's first write it as a
function and then I'll represent it that
way. So it's a function that says as a
function of what you offer me I have to
choose whether to accept that offer or
reject that offer. And here we're
looking at pure strategies. So it's a
function from zero, one, two, three
to
either accept or reject.
And how are we going to represent that
function? As you suggested
the way we normally write down
strategies is we put one blank space for
each of the information sets of the
player.
In this case, the player has four
information sets corresponding to the
four possible offers. So we have zero,
one, two, three.
And as an example, they might use a
strategy like this.
And this would be a a common strategy to
use in this game. This would say, "If
you only offer me zero or one,
I'm going to be upset with you. I'm
going to find it unfair, so I'm going to
reject that offer and kind of punish
both of us, right?
If you give me two or three, I'm very
happy and I'm going to accept that
offer. Uh I think it's fair. In fact,
you've given me a majority of the pot,
so I'm very happy and I'll accept it."
So, now let's see if we can find a Nash
equilibrium of this game involving this
strategy. So, remember Nash equilibrium
is a strategy profile. I've specified
one strategy.
Let's see Can we find a strategy for
player one that makes this into a Nash
equilibrium? So, let's think this
through. If you were player one, if you
were the proposer, and you expected or
you believed that the responder was
going to play in this way, how much
would you offer the responder?
Yeah, over here. Two.
Two. Great. So, we're going to have
exactly S2 equals S1 equals two. That's
confusing. And explain your reasoning.
Why would you offer two?
Cuz if you offer it lower, both of you
would get zero. If you offer more, then
you get nothing. So, you're in the
middle of the two.
Uh great. So, an another way of saying
that, exactly right, is I'm making the
lowest offer that will be accepted.
I don't want to offer any less because
there I'm clearly doing
uh
if I offer them less, I it gets
rejected. And if I offer them more, it
would be
uh
it it it will be accepted, but it'll be
worse for me, right? So, just to keep
track, let's say these offers
these offers are better for the
proposer,
right? If they're accepted, because I'm
offering less money to the respondent,
but they're not accepted.
So, when I say better for the proposer,
I mean better for the proposer if
they're accepted. The problem with these
is they're not accepted.
And then these higher offers are worse
for the proposer.
So, I make
the lowest offer, that is the offer
that's best for me if accepted, and I
find the lowest one that's actually
going to be accepted.
Okay. So, this indeed is going to be a
Nash equilibrium.
And let's check this formally. Let's
check that neither player has a
profitable deviation.
Okay?
If player one is offering two,
let's check that uh player two cannot
profitably deviate.
Well, if you're offering me two, there's
uh only two possibilities. I accept the
offer and I get two,
or I reject the offer and I get zero.
So, certainly I'm behaving optimally by
accepting the offer, right?
Now, let's go the other direction. This
is what we just reasoned through. Given
that this is the way that player two,
the responder, is playing, the best that
player one can possibly do is to offer
two, and that means keep one.
Because the only way they could get more
than one
is if they made one of these offers and
it was accepted, but that's impossible
given the strategy that the responder is
using.
So, we found one Nash equilibrium.
There's a lot of Nash equilibria in this
game, but there's something about this
Nash equilibrium that seems
wrong. Uh or maybe it seems problematic.
So, maybe I'll say, "What's wrong with
this Nash equilibrium?"
And this is exactly what we want to
capture today.
So, does anything feel
off to you? Does it feel like
there's a problem here? Yeah, in the
front. It seems like
one person's always beating the other.
Okay.
So, that's true, but some games are
unfair, right? So, I think I think
that's true. Maybe you're getting at it,
but I would say let's let's add a little
bit more to that. Yeah. So, it is true
that one player is always doing better,
but I can certainly write down games
where one player always loses. It
doesn't necessarily mean they're playing
irrationally. Um any other thoughts in
the front? Yeah. The responder should
accept one cuz that's positive utility.
Great.
So, this this information set seems a
bit puzzling, right? So, this says, "If
I'm offered one,
there are two choices for me.
I either accept one and I get my $1,
or I reject the offer and I get zero."
So, it seems that in this contingency,
accepting is strictly better than
rejecting. And if you're not motivated
by $1, let's call it a million dollars,
right? Then then it then it makes it
clear. I might be unhappy that you're
only giving me 1 million out of the 3
million,
but if my choice is take the 1 million
or reject it and get zero, it seems like
accepting is much better.
But why is this still consistent with
Nash equilibrium? So, I agree with you.
It seems like clearly
this is a we might call this a mistake,
or we might call this suboptimal.
But I thought Nash equilibrium said that
players are playing optimal given the
way their opponents are playing. So, why
is this allowed? It is a Nash
equilibrium, but someone's playing
suboptimal. So,
what's happening?
Yeah. Cuz we're basing it off of the
belief of how they're playing. Exactly.
So, player two believes
that player one is making an offer of
two.
If I believe that player one is making
an offer of two, I'm never going to
reach this contingency.
And because I'm never going to reach
this contingency, how I play at this
contingency doesn't affect my payoff
given the strategy of the other player.
So, what we've identified is kind of a
crucial
issue with Nash equilibrium, maybe a
limitation of Nash equilibrium,
that Nash equilibrium does not require
optimal play
at unreached contingencies.
We could be a little more precise.
Contingencies that are not reached based
on the play of the other player, but
I'll be a little vague here.
At unreached
contingencies.
And if we want to dig a little deeper,
when we analyze the Nash equilibrium of
this game, we converted this game into
strategic form.
And we said, "Well, what player does is
player What player two does is player
two chooses a complete contingent plan."
They just say, "If I'm offered zero,
I'll reject.
If I'm offered one, I'll reject. If I'm
offered two, I'll accept. And if I'm
offered three, I'll accept." And then
they form beliefs about what player
one's going to do.
So, this reasoning of the complete
contingent plan,
in some sense, it's missing something.
If I think about the complete contingent
plan approach,
it's missing the fact that a deviation
might be observable.
So,
doesn't capture
the observability
of deviations.
What do I mean by that? Well, the logic
of Nash equilibrium says,
"I have a belief that the that my
opponent is playing this strategy, and
given that belief, I'm going to choose
my contingent plan optimally." And
that's it. I have my contingent plan,
and then it gets executed.
But if player one is going to deviate,
well, I'm actually going to get to
observe that. Because if they offer me
one, I get to see that.
So, what this strategic form reduction
of the dynamic game seems to be missing
is the fact that if player one were to
deviate and play one, well, now I know
that they're not playing two anymore.
But the complete contingent plan
reasoning tells me, "Well, my play even
at this contingency is governed by by by
my belief that player one is off always
offering two." And it's ignoring the
fact that if we actually reach this
contingency, I learn that my opponent
has deviated and is not playing
according to my belief. So, the fact
that information arrives over time is
totally missed by the strategic form
because the whole
tree and the extensive form game are
missing from the strategic form
representation.
And that's going to be what we're going
to try to study kind of more formally
and more rigorously today.
So, today
we're going to define something called
backward induction.
And the basic idea is that backward
induction is going to require optimal
play even at unreached contingencies.
Obviously, at reached contingencies as
well, but what's new about it is that it
requires optimal play at unreached
contingencies.
And I want to make one more point about
this, that what we're doing today is
going to depend crucially on the
extensive form.
So, so far our approach in the class has
been to start with the extensive form to
try to capture the application we're
studying,
reduce it to the strategic form, and
then do all our analysis within the
strategic form.
And so far what we looked at, Nash
equilibrium, these various solution
concepts, rationalizability, only
depended on the strategic form,
but today we're going to take the
extensive form more seriously, and we're
going to argue that something might be
missing when we reduce the extensive
form to the strategic form.
So, let's see how this algorithm works
by looking at uh another
simple example. Let's look at the Boston
game again.
But in this case, the first player
chooses what sporting event to go, and
that move is observed.
So, the Boston game
with observed moves.
So,
what happens? We have
I'll draw it We can draw it either way.
I'll draw it up here. We have player one
first chooses to go to
the Celtics game or the Red Sox game.
And then player two
observes whether player one has chosen
the Celtics or the Red Sox, and then
they choose Celtics or Red Sox.
So, the original version of this game
that we studied was a simultaneous move
version of this game.
And in the simultaneous move version, we
would represent that by putting these
two nodes in the same information set.
Now, we're studying a different version
where player one's move is observed by
player two. And now, let's remember our
payoffs. I think the the convention
we've used is that player one prefers
Celtics to Red Sox.
So, if they both go to the Celtics game,
it's 2-1. If they both go to Red Sox,
it's 1-2, and then 0-0 and 0-0.
So, when I write
extensive form games this way, I'll put
the first player's payoff on top instead
of the left, but it has to the same
meaning. Instead of going
0,0 or 0,1, I'll just do 2 and then 1.
Okay, so first, let's represent this
game in strategic form.
So, we first have to understand the
strategies for the two players.
So, player one strategy set is pretty
simple.
They're just choosing Celtics or Red
Sox, so we just have C and R.
But player two strategy set is a bit
more complicated, just like we had
before. Player two has two information
sets.
So, their strategy should be a vector
with two components.
One component saying what they do here,
and one component saying what they do
here. So, we can write player two
strategies as CC, CR,
RC, and RR,
where the meaning is that we've agreed
that we're going to order our
information sets from left to right.
So, the first letter
says what player two does
at this information set,
and the second letter says what player
two does at this information set.
So, now we've defined the strategies, we
now need to write out the extensive
form.
All right, sorry, the strategic form.
So, we have CR,
and we have CC,
CR,
RC,
RR.
So, now we want to
fill in the payoffs here.
So,
if player one goes to the Celtics game,
when we're trying to compute payoffs,
what matters is the first entry
of player two strategy.
Because the first entry of player two
strategy precisely says what player two
does after they observe that player one
goes to the Celtics game.
So, under these two strategies, they go
to the Celtics game as well, and
therefore the payoff is
2-1,
2-1.
Under either of these strategies, player
one goes to the Celtics game, but player
two responds by going to the Red Sox
game. They're not at the game together,
and they both get a payoff of zero.
Now, let's look at what happens if
player one goes to the Red Sox game.
Now, it's the second component of the
strategy that determines the payoffs.
So, when do we both go to the Red Sox
game, it's actually going to be under
these two strategies. Cuz these are the
two strategies where player two goes to
the Red Sox game after player one does.
Uh so, we're going to have 1-2
and 1-2.
And then over here, we're going to have
0-0.
And 0-0.
Okay, so let's now try to compute the
Nash equilibria of this game. We're
going to use our standard trick.
Fixing a strategy of player two. Oh,
yes.
Can you clarify what the first letter
means in player two? Yeah, absolutely.
So, this means So, let me call these
information sets maybe
uh
IA
and IB.
This is
the first I'll use A so we don't get
confused with the first player. The
first information set of player two,
and this is the second information set
of player two. And this is what they do
at IA, and this is what they do
at IB. So, in words, let me use this
strategy This is a better example since
it's not constant. Uh at the first
information set, I play C, and at the
second information set, I play R. That's
my complete contingent plan.
Okay.
So, now let's try to compute the Nash
equilibria of this game.
So, as usual, we're going to fix the
strategy of player two and think about
how well player one does with their
different strategies. So, given that
player two does this, player one is
better off choosing C cuz two is greater
than zero.
Given here,
player two is better off here. Here, it
doesn't matter.
And here we go. Get this, right?
So, I'm just going column by column,
fixing player two strategy, and
computing player one's best response.
Now, I'm going to do it the other way.
I'm going to fix player one strategy and
compute player two's best response. So,
I'm going to get
this,
and this.
So, here I get three Nash equilibria.
Remember, a Nash equilibrium is going to
is can be visualized here by looking for
a cell that has both uh numbers
underlined.
So, we have three Nash equilibria.
Player one goes to the Celtics game, and
player two always goes to the Celtics
game.
Player two goes to Red Sox game, and
player two always goes to the Red Sox
game.
And then this one, where player two goes
to the Celtics game, and what player two
does depends on what they observe. So,
they go to the Celtics game if player
one goes to the Celtics game, but they
go to the Red Sox game if player two
goes to the Red Sox game.
So, we have three Nash equilibria. Which
of these Do I write this?
Which of these seems
most compelling to you? Which of these
seems kind of the most
reasonable? Or do they all seem
reasonable? Or do none of them seem
reasonable? I guess I gave it away.
Yeah?
The one on the
Uh CR. Okay, this one?
And tell me why.
I mean, they're getting like some sort
of payoff either way, or some sort of
positive
And if player one goes to the Celtics
game, he's always going to do something
good.
And if the first player doesn't go to
the Celtics game,
Right. So, I think what you're thinking
about is exactly even at the contingency
that's not reached,
this second player is doing pretty well.
Right? So, um the issue, if we look at
the first one or the last one, it is a
Nash equilibrium, but it but it involves
player two playing suboptimally at some
contingency.
Namely,
in this Nash equilibrium, player two
goes to the Celtics game even when they
see that player one has chosen the Red
Sox game.
That's suboptimal play because they'd
rather join them at the Red Sox game
than be all alone uh at the Celtics
game.
And similarly,
this strategy profile, well it is a Nash
equilibrium, involves suboptimal play at
the first contingency. Because player
two observes that player one has gone to
the Celtics game,
and they've responded not by going to
the Celtics game, but by going to the
Red Sox game.
So, each of these involves suboptimal
play at unreached contingencies, and
it's only this Nash equilibrium that
seems to have the special property of
optimal play at every contingency.
So, let's see how we could have tried to
identify this, you know, what algorithm
could we have used? I don't know if I
have
colored chalk, maybe not, so I'll just
highlight it.
Well, it's pretty intuitive to work
backwards, and I think this is how most
people, you know, approach problems like
this.
Let's kind of analyze this working
backwards. Let's start here
at these last information sets, and say,
"How should player two behave
optimally?"
If this information set is reached. So,
we'll look at player two, we'll say,
"Well, if we're here, we're certainly
better off getting one than zero. So,
I'm going to choose
this edge.
And then we'll come over here and say,
"If I reach this information set, I
don't know if we'll reach it, right? I
don't know how player one is playing,
but let's suppose that we get to this
contingency,
well, if I choose C, I get zero. If I
choose R, I get two, so R is better."
And then we can work our way up a step
further,
and now we can say, "Well, suppose I'm
player one, and I'm choosing how to
play.
I'm anticipating how player two is going
to play at each of these contingencies.
So, if I choose C, I anticipate we'll go
down here, and I'll get a payoff of two.
And if I choose R, I anticipate player
two will do this, and I'll get a payoff
of one.
Two is higher than one,
so I'll go here.
And sure enough, we've exactly
identified this special Nash
equilibrium.
When you apply this procedure, it's very
tempting to then you follow the path
down, and you say, "Ah,
2-1 is the answer." But no, 2-1 is just
the payoff.
The answer that you're looking for is a
strategy profile. The strategy profile
is player one plays C,
and player two makes a contingent plan
to play C at this information set and R
at this information
So now let's formalize this procedure.
Yes.
Yeah.
Right. So maybe what you're getting at
is let's look at player one's payoffs in
these equilibria. So we have this
equilibrium 2-1 that gives it's an
equilibrium that gives the payoffs two
and one.
And we have another Nash equilibrium
that gives the payoffs 1-2.
So you might say if you're player two,
you do better in this equilibrium than
this equilibrium.
And indeed this gets at kind of a
central issue
another way of thinking about backward
induction that
you know, how if let's suppose I'm
player two and I want to get to this
equilibrium. What would I do? Maybe I
would say something like look
I'm always going to go to the Red Sox
game. That's just who I am.
Whatever I see you do, I'm going to go
to the Red Sox game.
And it's almost like a threat, right?
Because the way I punish you is by just
saying I'm going to the Red Sox game
whatever you do.
Um the issue is that another way of
saying it is that this involves a
non-credible threat.
So let's understand why might player two
want to make this threat? It would be
great for player two if player one
believes that player two is always going
to go to the Red Sox game.
Because player two loves the Red Sox,
they'd love player one to believe that
because then player one will choose the
Red Sox themselves. The problem is if
player one thinks it through, they're
going to say wait a second, you're
threatening to go to the Red Sox game
whatever I do.
But if I actually go to the Celtics
game, are you really going to find it
optimal to follow through on that
threat? And the answer is no because
given that I'm going to the Celtics
game, you'd rather go to the Celtics
than go alone. So
one other way of thinking about backward
induction is that it's a principled way
of ruling out equilibria that involve
non-credible threats at contingencies
that are not reached. Great question.
Yeah.
Uh any other questions on this? Yes.
Then wouldn't you say that like offering
one to a person and then rejecting it is
a non-credible threat? Yes.
Uh so similarly this was a Nash
equilibrium that involves a non-credible
threat and therefore it's a Nash
equilibrium but it will not satisfy
backward induction.
So so in both of these cases these these
are very symmetric, right? In both cases
we have many Nash equilibria
but some of the Nash equilibria involve
non-credible threats and we're going to
introduce an algorithm called backward
induction that will rule out those
equilibria. But but I think the point
that could be confusing is even though
I'm saying this is not credible
it's still an equilibrium.
And similarly over here this was exactly
a non-credible threat but it was still
part of an equilibrium.
Any other questions? This is great.
Okay. So now let's
be a bit more formal
or just say what our
algorithm is. So this is we'll call this
the backward induction algorithm.
So we already did it here. Right? The
algorithm is you work backwards but
let's you know, say what that means.
Well first what's the input to the
algorithm?
And
formally the input to the algorithm is a
finite
extensive form game.
Really the important aspect of
finiteness is that the players alternate
moves only finitely many times.
If one player at some node can choose
among infinitely many strate- infinitely
many moves like choosing a number
between zero and a hundred, it's still
going to be okay but to be extra careful
we'll only we'll we'll kind of formally
define the algorithm for finite games
but we will be a bit informal and then
apply it to some infinite games that
where it won't create problems.
The other important aspect is it's an
extensive form game, right? The whole
point of this is that this algorithm is
faithfully capturing the dynamics of the
game and we wouldn't be able to observe
that if we started with a strategic form
game.
So notice this is fundamentally
different from Nash equilibrium. When we
define Nash equilibrium, our starting
point was a given strategic form game.
Here our starting point is an extensive
form game.
And the other final thing that we need
is this is a game with perfect
information.
What do I mean by perfect information? I
mean every information set is a
singleton.
And as long as information sets are
singletons, you could even have moves by
nature. That's okay but only moves by
nature that everyone gets to see. So
poker where you have a private hand,
that's not going to be perfect
information but if if nature flipped a
coin and everyone saw that, that would
be okay.
Can you see what would go wrong? Let's
say the these two nodes were in the same
information set and we tried to perform
the same procedure.
What would go wrong?
Well, if we're at this information set
and we tried to say how should player
two play at this information set, we
wouldn't know how to play because it
would depend on which of the nodes in
the information set we were at.
And later in the course we'll think
about how to approach that but for now
our algorithm later in the course just
in two days
but for now we're only going to apply
this to games of perfect information so
that at any node we get to, we know that
we're at that node and therefore we can
compute the optimal play. If we're at a
non-singleton information set and we
don't know which node we're at within
that information set, it's not clear
what optimal play is.
Okay. So this is our input and what is
our output?
We have to keep in mind that the output
is always a strategy profile.
It's not a pair of payoffs, it's the
full strategy profile and this is the
most common mistake I see. People just
list the payoffs they get at the end,
they follow the paths down and they say
2-1 but you really have to set specify
the full strategy profile.
Now I could formally define what the
algorithm is but I think you see how it
works, right? We I can introduce all
this notation and say you start at the
end and you play optimally and you work
your way backwards but I think it's just
easy to say you see how it is. But let
me talk about a few properties of this
algorithm, right?
So the output is not just any strategy
profile.
A first observation is that it is a pure
strategy profile.
Because at each point
we just choose one action. We don't need
any mixing.
Now if the player were indifferent at
some point you might have two choices.
There might be two ways they could play
optimally and in that case just choose
one arbitrarily.
So always break ties yourself.
Cuz at the end we always want to get a
pure strategy equilibrium when we apply
this.
And that kind of indicates another
property of this that in fact the output
is going to be unique
as long as there are no ties.
So as long as we never get to a point
where there's a tie
we never have any flexibility in what we
do. So when we work backwards, we're
always going to have
uh unique edge to choose. There's never
going to be multiple choices.
Uh and this isn't just going to be any
strategy profile. This is also going to
be a Nash equilibrium, right?
So what does this algorithm do?
It gives us a
pure strategy Nash equilibrium and in
unless there are ties, it always gives
us the same pure strategy Nash
equilibrium.
But let's
keep in mind kind of a warning.
As we already saw, there may be other
Nash equilibria.
So it's true that the output of this
algorithm is a Nash equilibrium but it's
a very special Nash equilibrium and it's
possible that there are other Nash
equilibria that would not that cannot be
outputs of this algorithm.
And those would be the Nash equilibria
that involve non-credible threats as
we've identified uh previously.
Now I think one
nice implication of this
that we shouldn't forget
is that recall
Let's recall
that some of the strategic form games we
looked at before did not have pure
strategy Nash equilibria.
>> Can anyone remember
an example of a game that doesn't have a
finite game that doesn't have a pure
strategy Nash equilibrium?
Yeah. Rock, paper, scissors. Rock,
paper, scissors is a great example,
right? So, it's unique Nash equilibrium
is for each mix 1/3, 1/3, 1/3.
So, wait a second.
Rock, paper, scissors doesn't have a
pure strategy Nash equilibrium, but here
I have an algorithm that always gives us
a pure strategy Nash equilibrium. So,
what's what's going on here?
Well, the input to our algorithm is a
finite extensive form game with perfect
information.
So, notice rock, paper, scissors is a
simultaneous move game.
If we wanted to represent rock, paper,
scissors in extensive form, we'd have
an information set with multiple nodes,
and therefore this would not be a game
of perfect information, and therefore
algorithm would not apply.
So, one implication of this algorithm,
you can think of it as a theorem, is
that every extensive form game with
perfect information has a pure strategy
Nash equilibrium.
Right? So, Nash's theorem told us that
any game has a mixed strategy Nash
equilibrium. Some games only have mixed
strategy Nash equilibria, but for this
special class of games with perfect
information, we always have a pure
strategy Nash equilibrium.
Um so, maybe I'll say, what's the answer
here? Perfect information games are
special.
And in fact, what's nice about this
algorithm, it doesn't just show that a
pure strategy Nash equilibrium exists,
it gives us an algorithm for finding it.
Whereas, computing Nash equilibria in
arbitrary games is generally uh much
harder.
And this actually formally
confirms a claim I made in a previous
class. If you recall, I said that the
value of chess
is +1, -1, or 0.
Can anyone see, I didn't actually check
that claim.
Can anyone see why this follows
from what we've
said so far?
So, we know chess has a value because
chess is zero-sum game. Right? But in
general, the value of a game could be
something like 0.3
or negative 0.7.
So, we know chess has some value that's
going to be between -1 and 1.
But how do we know that it has a value
that's either 0, -1, or 1, and not say
0.7?
Yeah. Win, draw, or loss.
So, those are the outcomes of the game.
That's true, but I can give you examples
of games. Let's take rock, paper, well,
let's take uh
Well, rock, paper, scissors is not a
good example. Um
the
Actually, hide and seek is also not a
good example. There are games I can give
you with ones and twos and and only
whole number payoffs where the value of
the game is not a whole number because
it involves mixing. So, uh rock, paper,
scissors,
if I slightly change things, I'd be able
to get that. Um so, that's we're not
That that shows that indeed the value
can't be below -1 or above 1. But in
principle, players could play mixed
strategies, and maybe the value We often
saw in zero-sum games that the security
strategies involved mixing, and that
meant that the value was uh you know, a
fraction. Yeah, uh but
I mean, I don't have the exact answer,
but it doesn't have something to do with
that.
One player might have one strategy
perfect information algorithm that
always know
what happened to the previous one
before.
Uh yeah, I think it's even easier than
that. They do have perfect information.
So, chess is a game of perfect
information. Whenever I move, I see all
the move I see the board.
And I know exactly how people have moved
before.
So, let's understand this. Chess is a
game of perfect information, PI,
which means I can apply backward
induction to chess in principle. Of
course, I can't actually do it because
the game tree explodes. Uh you know, no
computer, you know, the
the the the best ultimate video tips in
the world can't can't solve chess. Um
but because it's a game of perfect
information,
I know it has a pure strategy
Nash equilibrium
from backward induction.
And because it has a pure strategy Nash
equilibrium, well, because it's a
zero-sum game,
I know that in that pure strategy Nash
equilibrium, each player is actually
playing a security strategy.
So,
it must consist, because it's zero-sum,
that consists of security strategies.
And the payoff in that pure strategy
Nash equilibrium consisting of security
strategies is exactly the value of the
game.
So, in general, the value of the game is
always the payoff when each player plays
their security strategy, but often those
security strategies involve mixing.
Those are mixed strategies, and
therefore the payoff isn't necessarily
+1, -1, or 0. It could be something like
1/2.
But this tells us that in fact, the
value of the game is +1, -1, and 0. And
even more amazingly, it tells us that
the security strategies are pure.
So, if I say, how's what's the optimal
way to play chess? It's not, oh, I'm
going to randomize like it is in poker.
There's literally a book. It would be
bigger than, you know, the size of the
universe, but there there is a book I
could in principle write down that says,
given this move on the board, this is
how you should play.
Given this position on the board, this
is how you should play. And that would
ensure either that I always win,
depending on uh if the value is 1 and
I'm the first player, maybe I always
draw, or maybe the other player has such
a strategy. We just don't know in chess
uh who has the advantage.
In checkers, we do know, right? So,
what's the value of checkers? Anyone
know?
Yeah.
First player has won. Uh no, I think
it's actually zero. Uh I think checkers,
if people play optimally, I think it
ends in a tie. Uh though there may be
different variants of checkers, so I
have to check that. But uh I think in
standard checkers, it always ends in a
tie.
Uh yeah. So, when you say a game has a
value, what are you like referring
So, this is something specific to
zero-sum games that's a lecture we did
uh I guess on Thursday. Yeah. Um so,
it's referencing a previous lecture.
Yeah. I'm now happy to talk more after.
Yeah.
Uh
any any other questions on this?
Okay. So, now let's do
one final example
of backward induction,
and that will be
in another
quantity competition game.
So, so far we looked at Cournot
competition. Here, we'll look at
something called Stackelberg
competition. I mean, the names don't
really matter.
So, in Cournot competition, remember we
had two firms that were each choosing
how much to produce and how much to
bring to market.
But the assumption in Cournot was that
the firms move simultaneously.
And in Stackelberg, we're going to
imagine that there may be a first mover.
You know, maybe I harvest my crops
first, I get to choose to bring them to
market, and then the next farmer sees
how much I bring to market, and then
chooses how much to bring themselves.
So,
we have it's still quantity competition.
I want to emphasize this.
But it's
sequential quantity competition would
maybe be
You know, we often name these with
people, but if you don't know the
person, it's not a very meaningful name.
So, let's We might call this sequential
quantity competition
if you want a more descriptive title.
So, let's see how this works. We still
have two firms,
one and two.
And
they're choosing quantities as before.
And we have market demand.
Maybe I'll say inverse demand.
P of Q
equals to the maximum
of 1 - Q and 0.
So, this is exactly what we had before.
The more quantity that's brought to
market,
the lower the price is.
If quantity 1 is brought to market, the
price is 0. If quantity 0 is brought to
market, the price is 1, and the price
can never go negative. So, if tons is
brought to market, we just say the price
is 0. The market price is 0.
Uh
and let's also assume marginal cost c.
And as usual, we'll assume c is between
0 and 1.
So, remember marginal cost c means
whatever quantity Q of the good I
produce, it costs me c times Q to
produce that amount. So, it's a linear
cost, constant marginal cost.
But the key difference relative to
Cournot competition is that firm 1 moves
first.
And then firm 2
observes
firm 1's choice.
So, we can draw this we can try to draw
this in extensive form. It's a little
tricky because they're making choices
among infinitely many quantities. But if
we wanted to draw it, we would say,
here's firm 1.
They're making an infinite choice over
how much to produce.
Maybe we'll call this
Q1.
Maybe I'll take
particular point here. And then we have
firm two
who's making an infinite choice over Q2.
So, it's a little hard to formally
represent this in extensive form when
you have infinitely many things,
but what I mean here is
player one chooses a quantity Q1 to
bring to market, any non-negative
number.
Whatever quantity that is, player two
observes it. I'll warn you that it's
particularly hard to represent
information sets with infinitely many
players. So, it's crucial here
uh sometimes to write it in words that
player two observes the quantity that's
produced by player one cuz it's really
hard to draw information sets.
And then player two chooses the quantity
Q2.
All right.
So, now let's write down payoffs. The
payoffs are actually going to look
exactly the same as they did in Cournot
competition because the payoffs just
depend on how much each firm brings to
market. So, this is kind of like our BOS
game where the payoffs are the same
whether player two observes player one's
move or not, but the equilibria of the
game are going to be very different
depending on whether that move is
observed.
So, what are our payoffs? Let's look at
say firm one.
Well, as before
we want to say what is firm one's profit
pi one if they bring quantity Q1 to
market and firm two brings quantity Q2
to market.
So, we always have to think of profit in
two components. It's the profit per unit
times the number of units you have.
So, it's going to be Q1
times
what? Well,
maybe I'll write it like this.
Q1 is the amount I bring to market.
I sell it at a price of P of Q1 plus Q2
because Q1 plus Q2 is the total quantity
brought to market. That's what
determines the price.
And then of course, I also have to pay
my constant marginal costs per unit. But
let me plug in a formula here again with
my kind of little cheat that I'm going
to assume Q is not so big that this is a
negative number. So, I'm just going to
write this as Q1 times 1 minus Q1 minus
Q2 minus C.
Where technically this formula only
applies if Q1 plus Q2 is between 0 and
1, but in the end it will be. You might
say why are there two negatives? Well,
remember it's minus in parentheses Q1
plus Q2, and that's why I get two
minuses.
Okay. So, now we've specified
the payoffs. We still have to specify
strategies though.
And this I think is
where it gets a bit tricky.
Uh and the idea is let's start with
player one, firm one. Maybe I'll call
them F1 and F2 for firm.
What is a strategy for firm one?
Yeah. Whatever value of Q1 would lead to
the derivative of Q1 times 1
Well, now you're thinking about optimal.
Sorry, I'm just saying what is the set
of all strategies? Before we talk about
optimum, just So, a strategy for firm
I'm just saying what what is a strategy?
>> Any non-
Any
Any non-negative value. Yeah, so it's
just going to be Q1, right? Which we
have to choose exactly how much they can
produce. Let's say it's a number between
say 0 and infinity. So, a non-negative
number. Let's say that. The details
don't don't really matter.
Whether it's 0 to 1 or 0 to infinity, it
doesn't really matter. But what about
firm two? This is where it gets quite
subtle, right? What is a strategy for
firm two?
Well, if we took our our previous
approach, we'd have to get a vector and
we'd have to have a different spot in
the vector for every contingency. But
now there's infinitely many
contingencies. So, that's going to
become a bit messy. So, we really need a
function.
Right?
What kind of function is this going to
to be?
Well, firm two observes the quantity
chosen by firm one and then they choose
a quantity themselves.
So,
um
Sometimes it's might be easier to do 0
1, but I'll I'll stick this way. Stick
with it this way.
So, what does this say? What's the
interpretation? Yeah. But is C going to
be involved in this Is C going to be
considered a function or will C be
No, so C is uh a commonly known
parameter. It's known.
So, it doesn't It's not considered a
function.
No, because C is like two here, right?
It doesn't change. Um C is a known
parameter that affects the payoff
functions, but it doesn't affect the
definition of the strategies. So, you
think of it In a game, there's a
fundamental distinction between the set
of strategies, what people can do, and
the utility functions, which is how well
they do when they choose those
strategies. C is just, you know, we
could call it a half if we wanted. It's
just a known number that enters the
utility functions, but has no role in
the strategies. One way of seeing this
is if in this game I made this a three,
it wouldn't change the set of
strategies. It would just change the
payoffs people get from those
strategies.
And I could call this alpha and and the
same would be true. But that's
important. If C was private information,
then then it would get tricky, but it's
we're going to assume it's known and and
public. Everyone knows it.
Just like everyone knows this this
market function big P.
Great. So, what's the interpretation of
this? This says for any Q1 that I
observe,
what is the amount
Q2 of Q1 that I produce?
So, Q1 is the quantity that I observe
firm one producing.
Hypothetically, it's not how much they
actually produce, but it's if I were to
observe them producing Q1, how much
would I produce as firm two? I would
produce Q2 of Q1.
Okay?
Now, a big warning here.
I think this is maybe the fault of
sometimes the way we teach math. Um
Q2 is a function.
Q2 of Q1 is a number.
And this creates a lot of confusion
because in math class we often write f
of x, right? To mean a function. But
really f of x is a number. It's the
value of the function at x. So, it's
really important in this class that we
understand f by itself is a function.
f of x is a number, the value of the
function evaluated at x. So, on problem
sets,
it's really important that we understand
that the strategy for firm two is the
function Q2. People often say the
strategy is Q2 of Q1. But no, Q2 of Q1
is what is a number. It's the quantity
produced at a particular
uh contingency Q1. So, it's really
important that you kind of understand
function notation. If in doubt, you need
to, you know, on problem sets or on
quizzes, be very clear about what you
mean by things. Cuz if you say the
strategy is Q2 of Q1, we're not going to
really know if you mean a number or a
function because of sort of this
ambiguity that we have. So, uh try to be
precise.
Uh great.
So, now let's try to
actually analyze this.
So, now what we'd like to do is apply
backward induction to this game. Now, I
know technically I said it only applies
to finite extensive form games, but we
are going to be able to apply it here
and it won't be a problem. So, let's
apply backward induction.
And what are we going to do? Well, we're
going to work backwards like we always
do.
So, let's start here.
And we have to say
as a function of the amount Q1 that firm
one has produced, what should firm two
do?
So, let's consider maybe what I'll call
contingency
or info set
Q1.
So, this says put yourself in the
position of firm two. You've observed
how much firm one has brought to market.
And you've observed that the amount they
brought to market is Q1. And now you're
choosing Q2, how much you should bring
to market yourself.
So, what are you choosing? Well, you're
going to maximize
over Q2. Q2 is what you're choosing.
pi two
of Q1 Q2.
So, this is
essentially just what we did before when
we talked about computing a best
response, right? Given that Q1 is uh the
amount produced, I want to choose Q2 to
maximize my payoff where Q1 appears in
here because this is fixed. I can't
control this. This is already chosen.
And this is what I can control.
And what do we get? Well, this is Q2.
I'm just going to copy this formula, but
switch it because we're now focusing on
firm two.
1 minus Q1 minus Q2
minus C.
And if we use our trick,
this is something times a constant minus
that something. It's always optimal to
just do the something, the constant
Sorry. This is Q2 times a constant minus
Q2. It's always optimal to set Q2 to be
the constant divided by two.
So, what we're going to get is Q2, maybe
I'll say star of Q1
is equal to
So, we're almost there.
I just mechanically took a derivative,
but there is one issue I have to be a
little careful about. What if Q1 is
really really big?
So now my assumption that oh we don't
have to worry about negative prices, we
don't have to worry about max or min,
turns out we have to be a little bit
careful. If Q1, let's just think it
through, if Q1 is a billion,
what should firm two produce?
Nothing, right? Because if if if Q1 is a
billion, then the market price is zero.
My cost is C, so I definitely don't want
to produce anything. And fortunately it
turns out that if we just compute this
number and check if it's positive, we'll
get the right answer. So if it's
positive, we're good. If it's negative,
we set it to zero.
And we often the notation I'll use for
that is I'll put a little plus at the
bottom of it.
Uh or that's let me just write back.
I like that notation, but I think that
might just cause confusion. So let's
just write max
of this and zero.
More space.
Getting to Q two, okay.
So it's the
We have 1 minus
Q1 minus C over two, but if this is
negative, I just want to produce zero,
so I'm going to write the maximum of
this and zero.
I could use the plus, but I think this
is clearer.
>> [clears throat]
>> And I wrote Q2 star just to indicate
that this is going to be part of my
special backward induction strategy
profile.
Uh and let's understand
Q2 star at a particular Q1
is exactly this number, but by going
through this procedure, I'm going to
obtain a function Q2 star. So Q2 star
the function
is firm two's strategy.
It's the function where whatever Q1 you
plug into it, this is what you get out.
Okay, so now we go one step further.
So we work backwards, we figured out
what happens at
the second stage with firm two, and now
we have to figure out how firm one
should behave.
So now
we're at firm one.
Technically we're at the kind of initial
contingency, nothing is really happened
so far in the game.
And what is firm one's
problem? They're maximizing over Q1
what? They're choosing Q1 to maximize
what?
Any thoughts here?
Well, I think the first step is it's
going to be a profit, so let's put pi
one here.
And if they choose Q1, well definitely
Q1 should be the first component in
here.
But the hard thing is what do we put in
the second component? If I choose Q1,
what will firm two do? Yes?
Exactly. So what I'll put in here is Q2
star
of Q1.
So notice what I'm doing here as firm
one. I'm choosing how much quantity to
produce, recognizing that
when I choose Q1, that's going to
directly affect my payoff, but the Q1 I
choose is also going to affect how much
the other firm brings to market.
And specifically we can see that this is
a decreasing function of Q1. So the more
that I bring to market, the more the
next farmer sees, wow,
this person brought a lot to market,
that's really going to bring down the
market price, I'm going to I'm going to
bring less to market. So I can influence
how much firm two brings to market
through my choose a choice of Q1.
Uh and now we're just going to write
this substitute everything in and it and
we'll use the sort of trick that let's
hope that we never deal with the zero,
so let's assume everything's positive
and solve it and see what happens. So
we're going to get Q1
is the amount that I produce.
Then we're going to get
maybe I'll write it really carefully. Q1
plus
Q2 star of Q1
minus C
because for each unit I produce, I have
to pay a cost of C and I'm going to get
the market price. What's the market
price? Well, it depends on the market
production level, which is the sum of
what I produce and what I'm going to
induce firm two to produce.
So this is Q1 times 1
minus Q1
minus Q2 star of Q1
minus C.
Here this kind of a trick
we have 1 minus Q1 minus C minus
again 1 minus Q1 minus C, but over two.
So we have 1 minus Q1 minus C minus half
of it, so we have half left. So we're
going to get Q1 times 1 minus Q1 minus C
over two.
The Q2 star is gone because I
substituted in the expression for Q2
star above.
And if we it turns out the half here
doesn't actually affect the optimum
because we could just pull out the half
to the front and we're going to get Q1
star
equals 1 minus C over two if we do the
algebra.
It can be tricky to see this half here,
but remember if we just put the half in
the front, you can see if we multiply
the objective by a half, that doesn't
change the optimum. It changes the
optimal value, but not the optimum. So
we'll just get we'll just get this.
Now, let's be really clear about this.
The algorithm has told us a strategy
profile. It said firm one is producing
this amount
and firm two is using this complete
contingent plan
that specifies what they produce as a
function of every Q1. But now we like to
understand, well how much is actually
produced?
Because
all we know is firm two's complete
contingent plan, let's figure out the
actual production level for firm two.
What is that going to be?
Well, we need to plug in
we what what I want to look at is Q2
star is the strategy that backward
induction gave us for firm two, but now
I'm going to plug into that function the
strategy that backward induction gave us
for firm one, which is just a number,
the quantity.
And this is going to tell me how much is
actually produced as opposed to firm
two's complete contingent plan.
And
I have to be a little careful here. It's
1 minus C over two minus
quarter and I think it should be 1 minus
C over four.
Okay?
So now we've we've analyzed the game.
Uh but now we can ask we've analyzed it
mathematically, let's ask some econ
questions about it.
And in particular we've looked at how
much each firm produces in the
equilibrium. Does anyone recall if we
did Cournot with two four firms
how much each firm produced?
Remember?
We had the same with the same demand
function, the same costs.
No,
I'll say it's 1 minus C over three.
Okay?
So
can anyone comment on the differences
here? So in Cournot
Q1 star equals Q2 star
equals 1 minus C over three. So when the
firms move simultaneously, they both
produce 1 minus C over three.
When the firms move sequentially, firm
one produced 1 minus C over two and firm
two produced 1 minus C over four.
Any intuition for why
why we get this?
What's the key difference here? Let's
think of it from firm one's perspective.
What's the key difference in firm one's
optimization problem between the
simultaneous move Cournot game
and the sequential move game? Remember,
we already saw in the Boston game that
simultaneity versus sequential play can
have a big difference.
Yeah.
In the
Cournot game like they both have a
better choosing the same quantity rather
than having a choice.
And my
follower is
doing the same thing while my follower
is having a choice.
Um Stackelberg or sequential quantity
competition? Yeah?
Q1 or player one has a choice like
player two is going to know player two
is obviously not going to produce so
much as possible rather than what player
one does. So I I think the one word you
said there was crucial, you said firm
one can influence firm two. And I think
that's the crucial thing. So let's think
about the Nash equilibrium reasoning in
Cournot. In Cournot, I'm taking as given
the amount that my opponent is producing
and I'm saying given the amount that
they're producing, the amount that I'm
producing is optimal. Taking as fixed
the amount they produce.
Here it's fundamentally different
because because I move first, I know
that my choice of quantity affects how
much they produce. So I know if I
increase my production, I can cause them
to decrease their production. So that
makes more production for firm one more
attractive, right? In general, I don't
want the other person to produce cuz
that brings down the price. So if I know
that by raising my production, I can
decrease their production, that gives me
a further incentive for me to raise my
production level.
So that's why firm one produces more.
Firm two's choices actually looks very
similar. Firm two takes firm one's
quantity as given. So firm one's
incentives are essentially the same
sorry, firm two's incentives are
essentially the same, but the issue is
firm one is producing so much more, it's
optimal for them to produce a lot less
than than in Cournot.
Um so what's key the key word you used
is influence.
Can my quantity influence the quantity
that you choose?
All right, so now we found we've applied
backward induction. We found a
particular Nash equilibrium that seems
reasonable to us. It doesn't involve any
credible any non-credible threats. But
it's still good to keep in mind, could
we find any other Nash equilibria
that do involve credible threats?
So, could we find
other Nash equilibria
that maybe we don't find compelling, but
just to understand
what's going on here? What would be a
kind of threat that firm two might be
tempted to make if we think back to our
reasoning about you know, we gave the
example of I'll threaten to always go to
the Red Sox game whatever you do. What
might be a threat that firm two might
want to impose to try to benefit
themselves if we had a very smart firm
two. Yeah?
Like the firm could produce a lot, drive
price down, so that firm one firm one
won't make any money and that that would
provoke the firm one to produce Great,
exactly. So, firm two can make a threat.
Firm two might threaten
there's even a term for this to flood
the market, meaning produce a huge
amount of quantity to pull down the
market price.
Uh but let's say a little more. When
would they want to impose this? When
would they flood the market? Under what
conditions or what circumstances?
What does firm two want firm one to do?
Produce a lot or a little?
You can answer or someone else can
answer. Yeah. Well, I guess firm two
would want firm one to produce 1 - c
over 4.
Um well, in general they actually might
want them to produce either even less,
but in general they want them to produce
not very much, right? So, when would
they threaten when would they flood the
market? Under what? When they produce
too much. When they produce too much,
right? So, what firm two might say is,
"Look,
you better keep your
production level low
because if you produce too much, I'm
going to flood the market." So, firm two
might threaten to flood the market if
firm one
produces too much.
And this actually gets into dynamics
that we'll study later. You know, oil
cartels essentially function exactly in
this way, right? I might say, "You need
to keep production low, and if you
don't, I'm going to punish you by
flooding the market." Yes. How would
this be a credible threat though because
firm two loses money by flooding?
So, this will not be a credible threat.
That's why it didn't survive our
backward induction procedure, but it
will be a Nash equilibrium. So, what I
want to illustrate is how a Nash
equilibrium can involve non-credible
threats.
Backward induction rules out those
non-credible threats, but Nash
equilibrium can allow them if we if we
design them carefully.
Uh other question. Yeah?
If you remove some of the simplifying
assumptions we make for this Mhm. making
a credible threat with things like
infrastructure and capital investments
in production capacity? I think the the
best way to make it credible would be to
say it's a repeated game, and that's
what we'll study later on, right? We're
assuming it's a one-off thing, but
really what might happen is every day we
come to market and I might say, "Wow, if
day after day you keep doing this, then
I'm going to do this." And then we can
get these complicated rewards and
punishments over time. And that's going
to be a big focus of the second part of
our course. Uh so, that's a good way to
make it credible. Yes. So, this is where
a Nash equilibrium So, this is a Nash
equilibrium. It's the idea that firm one
knowing firm two can threaten the market
Exactly. So, let's let's actually
construct a Nash equilibrium because we
haven't constructed one yet. So, let's
fix some number Q1
um
which is let's say really small.
So, let's say it's it doesn't really
matter
uh exactly
but we do
Let's say 1 - c over 4. It doesn't
matter.
And now
what is Q2 star going to be?
Um
Well,
let's use our idea
that there's a few different ways we can
do it, but let's use an idea that
they're going to threaten to flood the
market if production is too high.
Right? So, let's look at two cases.
If Q1
is less than Let me call this Q1 bar.
If Q1 is less than Q1 bar and if Q1 is
greater than or
less than or equal to and greater than
Q1 bar.
So, if Q1 is greater than Q1 bar, firm
two is going to flood the market. Again,
the exact amount doesn't matter. Let's
say 100. It doesn't matter.
Uh
what if Q1 is less than or equal to Q1
bar? We actually have to be a little
careful to make sure it's still a Nash
equilibrium, so let's um
follow our idea here and let's make this
1 - Q1 - c over 2.
Okay?
There's many examples, and we could
figure out exactly how big Q1 bar can
go, but I think this one should work.
And let's just see that we understand
that this is a Nash equilibrium.
So, given Q2 strategy, why is this the
optimal choice of Q1? Can anyone explain
in words?
I mean, we see the math, but can we
explain in words?
Well, why don't I want to produce more
than this?
Yeah. That's like the most you can
produce without the market getting
flooded. Exactly. So, if I produce it's
the most I can produce without flooding,
and you can check that when the market's
not flooded my payoff is going to be in
is going to be increasing at least until
this point. So, if I produce less than
this, the market doesn't get flooded,
but I'm producing so little I'm not
doing very well. If I produce more than
this, that would be good if the market
didn't get flooded, but if I produce
more than this, the market gets flooded,
so I don't want to do it. Okay? So,
player one is behaving optimal given
firm two's strategy.
How can we see that firm two is behaving
optimally given firm one's strategy?
What's the one There's sort of only one
aspect of this strategy that's important
if we want to check that it's a Nash
equilibrium.
What's important is when firm one
chooses Q1 bar
which is in this case firm two responds
optimally.
Cuz that's the only thing that affects
firm two's payoff. What they do in the
contingency that's actually reached. So,
you can check that given that firm one
is producing this amount firm two is
going to produce 1 - Q1 bar - c over 2,
and it turns out that's optimal for firm
two given firm one's behavior. So, this
will be a Nash equilibrium, but it's not
it doesn't survive backward induction.
What is a contingency at which firm two
is behaving suboptimally?
Well, really anything up here. Actually,
not if Q1 is really really high, but uh
if Q1 is anywhere between Q1 bar and 1 -
c
firm two could respond and make positive
profits, but they're instead flooding
the market causing the price to drop to
zero and making profits of zero.
So, at unreached contingencies firm two
is behaving suboptimally. That's why
this doesn't survive backward induction,
but at the reached contingency they are
behaving optimally, and that's why it
constitutes a Nash equilibrium. And let
me stop there and I'll see you on
Thursday. Thank you.